[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIRELA CUNJALO: My
name is Mirela Cunjalo.
I'm a director of product
management at Teradici,
and I'm presenting today with
my colleague Paul right here.
PAUL PAVLIK: Hello, everyone.
I'm Paul Pavlik,
I'm the director
of software development
at Teradici.
MIRELA CUNJALO: Thank you.
So what we'll be
talking about today
is why you might want to
virtualize your workstations.
We'll show you how
you can [? damage ?]
and manage it efficiently,
and we'll have a great demo
that Paul will
show, and hopefully
five to 10 minutes of
questions at the end as well.
OK.
Some of you are familiar with
Teradici, some of you are not.
So I wanted to do a
quick overview of who
we are as a company for you.
So we were founded in
2004, at which time
we invented a revolutionary new
protocol for remoting desktops
and workstations called PCoIP.
And since then, we now
have about 13 million users
worldwide directly through us
or through our OEM partnerships.
And these customers are
deploying on-premises,
in public clouds,
hybrid environments,
all sorts of mixed
environments like that.
And customers include
Fortune 500 companies
across many different
industries--
so federal government, for
example, media entertainment,
manufacturing, education,
finance, and more.
Also, as a company,
we work very closely
with technology partners
like Google, like NVIDIA
in order to provide the best
solutions for our customers.
OK.
So getting into the
workstation use cases.
So here are a few use cases
for high-performance remote
workloads.
A lot of these are type
customers that we've seen
and how they use it across
the different verticals.
So I'll go through all of them.
Media entertainment,
example would
be visual effects workloads,
video editorial-- so creating
movies and editing
movies, creating
visual effects for movies.
Federal government, examples
here for workstations
that require GPUs would be
data modeling simulation.
So for example, flight
vehicle training
and simulation,
geospatial mapping,
those are examples there.
Manufacturing and engineering,
generally CAD workloads--
3D and 2D CAD workloads.
This is automotive as well
as architecture, engineering,
construction type of firms.
And actually, also,
autonomous driving development
fits in there as well.
For finance, it
would be trading.
Generally, trading
requires high performance.
They also have a lot of very
large screens at their desks.
And for higher education,
most workstation use cases
for higher education would
be around STEM subjects--
so Science, Technology,
Engineering, and Math--
and things like lab
work, online learning,
and training and testing
for STEM subjects as well.
And for health care, it's
primarily medical imaging.
OK.
So what are the key challenges
that these type of customers
face when they have workstation
high-performance workloads?
So number one that
we see the most often
is that they need to
protect their valuable IP.
So imagine a media
entertainment studio
creating next "Avengers" didn't
want a spoiler to leak out,
and the federal government
didn't want any classified data
to leak out.
So it really is number one
for all of those use cases
I described.
Another one is
on-site hardware is
expensive to scale and manage.
So if you are
purchasing workstations,
they are under the desk.
If you need to scale,
grow, hire more people--
contractors-- or vendors need
to get access and work with you,
it's more complicated
to have to wait six
weeks to get the workstation.
And you may not need
it all year long.
Did you get your ROI on it?
That's a common problem as well.
And then, modern and
mobile workforces
are demanding offset access.
So this is people collaborating.
This is people wanting
to work from home.
It's more and more common,
have that work-life balance.
And with workstations,
the 3D models,
the graphics-intensive
workloads, the content
itself is increasing in
size as well as complexity.
So when teams and different
vendors or contractors
have to collaborate
together, it's
more and more difficult
because the content
itself is more complex.
And there's the need to have
geographically-dispersed teams.
You might want to hire people
from different locations
in the world because
of cost savings,
because a company may have
purchased another company, lots
of reasons.
OK.
Those are the challenges.
And here, I covered how
virtual workstations
can address those challenges.
These are not all of them.
There's a lot more to it, but
these are a few highlighted
ones.
And this is together with
public cloud like Google
as well as our PCoIP
technology and all the benefits
you get out of it.
One is that it improves
productivity and efficiency.
So now that your workstation
is no longer under your desk,
it's somewhere else
consolidated in a public cloud
or in a data center, you get
to access it from anywhere.
That means you can have
those dispersed teams.
You don't need to worry
about different team
members downloading data
to their workstation
to work on it then uploading
so the other person can
see what changed.
It's just more
efficient this way.
And working from
home, there's been
lots of case studies
done around that,
how it improves efficiency in
collaboration by 25% or more.
So it's generally a more
efficient way to work.
And lastly, it does enable
companies to hire global talent
from anywhere.
So they don't have to
feel the labor pinch
having to locally hire in
whatever office they're in,
in whatever city they are in.
They can hire anywhere and
benefit even from taxes--
tax deductions, as well.
Another one is that you can
realize unprecedented security
and protect your IP.
So with our technology, when
you remote your workstation
somewhere else,
firstly, again, you're
not downloading the data.
So it's not
somewhere on a device
that somebody is taking,
traveling with, working
from home with.
The data is somewhere safe in
the cloud or the data center.
And with our technology, what
we do is we look at that desktop
that you are working within--
like an application, Autodesk
Maya, AutoCAD, or something
like that.
We just encrypt and
encode the desktop,
and we transmit only encrypted
pixels to the client device,
not the actual data.
So the data is
protected in a cloud.
It never gets sent
to the client device,
and that's really important.
And second, if you're
using Google Cloud--
I mean, as you have seen
at the keynote and a lot
of the sessions here,
they've put a lot of effort
into security, like
compliances, certifications,
encryption of your
data, lot of products
that they offer around security.
So the combination of the
two makes it more secure.
By virtualizing, it also
increases your agility
and scalability.
So you can get on-demand access
to latest tech all the time--
and as much of it as you want.
So for example, NVIDIA
launched a new GPU, T4,
and you get to utilize it
immediately rather than
wait for you to order it, to
arrive, to get it and use it.
And hopefully, when you
purchase something on-premises,
you hopefully we
use it all the time.
Otherwise, you
don't get your ROI.
With public cloud, you get the
scale, use it-- a lot of it.
And then, if you
don't use it anymore,
you don't pay for it anymore.
It's that OpEx versus CapEx
model and the benefits of that.
And lastly, by virtualizing
your workstation,
you really realize the full
potential of the cloud.
So you are moving your
data to the cloud,
consolidating your data
with your compute--
so all the compute
power for rendering,
high-performance computing--
but you're not doing
the workstation.
So whatever your result
is of your render,
now you have to
download it and work
on it if it's an application.
When you move, you co-locate
your data, your compute,
and your graphics.
You move your workstation
where your data is.
You get to benefit
fully from the cloud.
And really, this is
only possible if,
when you are virtualizing, that
you have that really great user
experience.
You can expect your
high-performance users
to use their
workstations sluggish
or less distortions on it.
That's where we come in.
We ensure that
their performance is
as if it's under the desk
rather than somewhere else.
OK.
So why Teradici?
Why our technology?
I've covered a little
bit previously on it,
but this is a bit more detailed
based on our workstation
customers and what
their needs are.
So high-performance
user experience.
What we do is our protocol
provides the highest image
quality with efficient
build-to-lossless
So what that means
is, when you're
looking at an image
virtualized and on-premises,
it's 100% color accurate,
lossless, build-to-lossless,
and highly interactive
and low latency,
which is what these type of
users really, really need.
Also, what we do in terms
of high-performance user
experience is that we
automatically adjust
to changing network conditions.
So if your users are working
from home or traveling wherever
they are-- using a tablet
maybe somewhere in the field,
example would be architect going
on site and looking at his 3D
drawings on his tablet--
well, the network is
very different from when
he is in the office.
We automatically adjust and give
you the best user experience.
There's no need to do some
change settings, et cetera.
We also offer ultra secure
remoting and endpoint
architecture.
Like I said, we just encrypt
and transmit pixels--
AES-256 encryption as well.
And no data ever gets
to the client device.
Again, I'll emphasize here
that one of our verticals
is the federal government--
it's quite a big
vertical for us--
because of the security that
we offer with our technology.
And also, ease of
deployment and management.
We understand that, if you're
managing virtual workstations,
you want to make sure that
you can do that efficiently
and effectively.
And we do that as well with
the tools we provide you.
And Paul will demonstrate
that later on as well.
And we also support widest
platform flexibility.
This means multi-cloud.
This means any public cloud,
on-premises, mix of those.
Whatever suits your
needs we can do.
So I haven't said yet what
the product is called.
It's called Cloud Access
Software, Teradici Cloud Access
Software, and it's built on
top of the PCoIP technology
that I've been talking about.
OK.
I wanted to bring this up
because it was also brought up
at the Tuesday keynote
as well, that enterprises
have a multi-cloud strategy--
either have it now,
already are multi-cloud,
or going multi-cloud.
So this is a pretty
high percentage, 84%.
So if you are thinking
about going to the cloud
and you're worried,
it's quite common
to have a mixed environment
where certain projects go
to the cloud.
Maybe you burst into
the cloud, or you might
be going fully into cloud.
It's up to you
and your business.
So this here shows that,
with Cloud Access Software,
we support all phases of
your journey to the cloud,
whether you want to be
just on the data center
today, virtualized or not
virtualized, and just a burst
in the cloud a little bit
or go fully to the cloud.
Whatever you are today or
where you want to go later,
we can support all
those scenarios already.
So speaking of that
hybrid environment,
here's an example architecture.
As you can see, an
on-premises and a public
cloud version workstations.
So the on-premises, there
are two that show virtualized
and a hypervisor--
ESXI or KVM hypervisor, and
also non-virtualized ones.
And on the public
cloud, Google Cloud,
you have some VMs as well.
That's where you
install our software.
And what the end user
will do that's sitting
at their desk working on,
let's say, a CAD workload,
they would basically
install a software client
on their laptop.
It's on a
workstation-style laptop.
It's just a lower-level laptop--
Mac, Windows, Linux, whatever,
as well as mobile, Chrome OS,
Android, iOS tablets--
and the PCoIP Zero client, which
is a hardware client device
that we have that has our chip
in it and no application OS.
For example, for
education, they might
be using a Chromebook to
connect to Autodesk, AutoCAD,
or something running
in the public cloud.
So they're using a
simple Chromebook
to do that sort of
high-intensity work.
OK.
So let's say you do
virtualize your workstations.
And if you do, you need a way
to efficiently manage them.
And there's reasons
why you might
want to efficiently manage
and obviously save time
and money to manage your users.
What we offer is a Cloud
Access Manger service for you
to be able to do
this, and this is what
Paul will demonstrate as well.
And some of the features and
capabilities that it gives you
is that it improves
administrative efficiency
because it automatically
provisions your workstations
for you.
So you don't have to manually
go through a bunch of steps
to do it.
You can scale easily.
You can add more workstations,
remove workstations,
scale up and down easily.
And third one on there is about
managing cloud consumption
costs.
So that's a big thing.
If you are using a
public cloud and you're
using the OpEx
versus CapEx model,
you don't want to be paying for
something you're not currently
using.
So Cloud Access Manager
helps with that.
If you're not
using it, shut down
so you're not
paying for compute.
And if the user wants to
use their workstation,
they can just log in
and get access to it.
And, of course, lastly, it's
that it brokers the connection
from the user to
the workstation.
So when I log in
to my client, I'm
presented only with the desktops
because I've been authorized
access by my administrator.
OK.
I won't cover all these, but I
want to cover a couple of them
that our workstation
customers care about.
4K UHD resolution,
we do support that.
So most customers are still
HD, but they're going to 4K
for various reasons.
It could be content
they're working on is 4K.
It could be just they
need the real estate,
so they're buying 4K.
And it's becoming
cheaper and cheaper.
We support both Windows
and Linux environments.
So when I was talking
about all those use cases,
some use cases are
purely Windows.
The applications they're using
are only running on Windows.
Some of them are purely Linux.
Some are mixed.
We don't care.
It works with all of them.
And additionally, I know we're
talking about workstations
here, but we support also
normal users like office workers
and task workers as well--
not just workstation users.
We have a version of our
software for that, too.
And this is an
example of something
where we put an
effort into providing
low-latency peripheral support.
So some of our users in media
entertainment, for example,
need to use tablets like this.
And it's very important
to them that they
feel-- the monitor is on
like a 20-millisecond latency
between the user and
workstation, they feel it,
and they can't use it.
So we developed technology
to make that feel
like it's under the desk.
This is a little
bit of advertising.
We introduced and announced
last week PCoIP Ultra.
This is our latest
protocol enhancements
in terms of performance.
As you can see, we continuously
improve our performance
based on the needs
of the workstation
users in the industry.
It is changing.
So this latest upgrade means
4x encoder performance.
So you could do 4K resolutions
at up to 60 frames per second.
Here's an example of what
our customers are saying.
Sony Pictures Imageworks is
one of our long-time users
of our technology.
And you can see here--
I'll read it out--
"Teradici Cloud Access
Software on Google Cloud
will allow us to rapidly scale
and burst virtual workstations
for our visual effects
artists using NVIDIA GPU cloud
instances, enabling our
studio to meet tight project
timelines."
It's what I was
talking about earlier.
One of the benefits of
utilizing virtual workstations
and public cloud is that
you get a competitive edge
against your competitors.
This is another customer.
You can read a lot more about
this one on our website,
but I just wanted to
highlight one thing
that they benefit
from as well that I
didn't talk about earlier.
When they moved a workstation
away from the artists under
the desk-- somewhere else--
they said that the working
environment was so much more
pleasant because it's quieter,
there's no heavy workstations.
It's just a simple client
that they're working with.
And it felt cooler, as well,
because with the workstation
it was quite hot in the rooms
where they were working.
All right.
So if you wanted to try it
out, Cloud Access Software,
we do have it on
the GCP marketplace.
That's one way to try it out.
You can also reach out to
us and get a trial license
as well outside of this.
And I also want to call
out that NVIDIA has also
released a Google
Cloud Marketplace
image for their Quadro Virtual
Workstation for their T4.
So it's something you
could try it out today.
If you use it, you can remotely
access it with our technology.
And it's available,
it looks like,
in eight different regions.
Just to show you,
this is a demo.
It's a really cool demo that
they have at their booth.
At the end, I'll show a
slide of the different booths
that you can visit that
have our technology in it.
There's several, and this
is one you could go see.
OK.
So that was it on my part.
I think you're probably
all waiting for a demo.
Paul, go ahead.
PAUL PAVLIK: Great.
Can everyone hear me OK?
Great.
Yeah, thanks a lot, Mirela.
So what I'm going to
be doing this morning
is I'm going to show you--
well, if we can just switch back
to the slides for a quick sec,
that would be appreciated.
I'm going to show you the
architecture of what I've set
up and what I'm going to demo.
And so, what I've got is two
different regions where I've
got remote workstations
in GCP US East,
another region remote
workstation set up in GCP West.
And I've also got remote
workstations set up
on-premises.
Since we're in Vancouver,
I decided to put them
in Vancouver for this demo.
And so, what we require is
for you as users of PCoIP
to install this connector.
We call it the Cloud
Access Connector.
And that effectively
allows your PCoIP clients
to connect directly to
your remote workstations.
These clients, as
Mirela said, we
support various
types of devices--
the [? 30g0 ?] client,
the PCoIP IP client
running on Windows, Linux, OS
10, iOS, and Android devices.
But when you connect into
your remote workstations,
we don't require
the use of a VPN.
Inside the Cloud
Access Connector,
we have a security
gateway that effectively
acts as the [? net. ?] And
also, what is connected to Cloud
Access Connector is
your directory service.
Currently, we
support Microsoft AD.
We will be supporting
other directory services
in the near future.
And I was really happy to hear
Google's announcement yesterday
with their support for
Microsoft AD as well.
And what coordinates
all of this is
we've developed a
Cloud Access Manager
service that runs in the cloud.
You have a single
management console
to administer all these machines
as well as entitle users
to those machines.
I'm just going to geek
out for a couple seconds,
but I'm really proud
of what we developed.
This Cloud Access
Manager service
was developed as a
cloud-native application
right from the beginning.
We built it on
top of Kubernetes.
We've embraced
all the principles
between SRE and DevOps,
as well as we've
built it as a 12-factor app.
Lots of exciting things
happening in the cloud world,
and we're happy that we
could take advantage of that.
So now, if we can jump on to the
demo computer, that'd be great.
What I'm going to
do is I'm just going
to show you our PCoIP
connection quickly just so you
get a sense of what it's like.
And then, I'm going to show
you our administration console.
And as you can see, we
run on even old laptops
such as this one here.
So I've got our PCoIP
client already installed
on his windows laptop.
I'm going to kind of go through
the manual connection just
to show you how we do it.
So I'm just going to
type in the IP address.
Sorry, I had it in my buffer,
but I guess it got lost.
And so, this is the IP address
of the Cloud Access Connector
that is in your subscription.
And so, I'm going to
enter in my credentials.
Make sure I get it right.
And I have to admit,
as I was preparing
for this presentation, I found
myself constantly speaking
out loud my password.
So I apologize if
I do that today.
OK.
So I've been authenticated
against my AD credentials.
I'm presented with a list
of remote workstations
that I've been previously
authorized to access.
So I'm just going to jump onto
this one and do a connection.
And so, what's happening
now is the PCoIP connection
is being directly established
through the Cloud Access
Connector to the
remote workstation
in your subscription on GCP.
So here, you can see I've got
a Windows machine running.
I've got the NVIDIA.
I selected the NVIDIA Virtual
Workstation with the P4 GPU.
And this is just to
kind of highlight
all the different
things that you
can do with the remote
workstation here.
So I'll just make sure.
And one thing I like
to kind of demo--
and I'll see if I can demo this
quickly since this is a live
demo--
let's see if I can go to it.
I'm just going to run this
speed test in the background.
I just chose this one.
As it's running, I
just want to highlight,
if your data is in the cloud
and you're doing your analysis
in the cloud and you're
visualizing in the cloud,
why not actually have your
desktop in the cloud as well?
And so, here, you see the
download speed I'm getting--
just around one gigabit
or just slightly
below one gigabit per second.
And now, I'm going to
do my upload speed,
and it's kind of creeping
up towards one gigabit.
So I just wanted
to highlight that.
And the latencies,
again, if you've
got your data in
the cloud and you've
got your remote
workstations in the cloud,
the latency between them can
be actually very, very low.
I'll keep that running
in the background,
and I'm just going to connect
to another remote workstation.
I'll do the same thing as
before, the same IP address.
Oops.
That's not the same.
Sorry about that.
And I'll enter the
same credentials
as I entered in before.
And I'm going to select
a different workstation,
and I'll connect to it now.
OK.
And here it is.
So this is a
different workstation,
but you can see
it's not Windows.
Here, I'm running CentOS 7 on
GCP with an NVIDIA P4 as well.
So we support [? Rel. ?]
And for people
in the crowd who
are developer types,
I know that you prefer Ubuntu,
and we support that as well.
And here's just another
simple WebGL application
that I like to quickly demo.
Just kind of shows the
capabilities of the GPU
very quick.
So that's really neat to see.
Cool.
So how do we make this happen?
So I'm going to log into the
Cloud Access Manager portal.
It's at cam.teradici.com.
Today, I'm actually
showing you our beta UI,
and that's why it's
represented in the URL.
We support different
identity providers to log in.
We support Microsoft and Google.
Since we're at Google Next, I'm
going to log in with Google.
So I've got my Teradici
demo account on Gmail.
I'm just going to log in.
It didn't ask me
for my password.
I just logged in
about 20 minutes ago.
So with the Cloud
Access Manager,
there's three kind of concepts.
There's deployments, connectors,
and remote workstations.
Remote workstations
I'll get to in a second.
But with deployments, say
you're a managed service
provider where you're
managing different customer
accounts on their behalf.
In that case, you would want
to have multiple deployments
per customer where you'd
have a different AD
and different cloud credentials
to provision those machines.
Another example of where you'd
want multiple deployments is
say you want an area for
your sandbox environment
so you can do all your sandbox
testing before modifying
your production environment.
Another example is
disaster recovery.
You might want to set up an
entirely different deployment
for your DR site.
And then, connectors, these
are the three connectors
that I was showing in the
architecture diagram earlier.
We've got the Vancouver
on-premises one, the GCP US
East, and the GCP US West.
And you can monitor the
health of the connector,
especially if the
connector goes down.
And then, from the
connector, there's
a couple different
things you can do.
You can create a new
remote workstation.
Creating a remote
workstation is where
you would provision a
remote workstation where we
would do that on your behalf.
And we would install
the software,
install the NVIDIA
drivers if you
decide to use a
graphics agent machine,
as well as actually
add it to the domain
such that you can
have your users log in
with a single sign-on
user experience.
So I'm just going
to kind of quickly
show what it looks like for
the simple user interface.
So here, I can select a
Windows or a graphics machine.
I'll just enter my name.
And then, since I've already
set this up with GCP,
here are all the different
regions and zones
that you can select from.
I'm just going to
select the region where
I know there's NVIDIA machines.
I've already set
up my networking,
so I'm just going to
select my network.
I'll just choose that one.
And then, machine type, you
can select different types.
And then, here are the
different GPU types.
So today in this region, I
see the Tesla P100 and the P4.
A couple days ago, NVIDIA
announced the T4, which
is really exciting as well.
And once that becomes
available in the region,
it will automatically show
up in our interface here.
So I'll just select a
P4, and you can select
how many GPUs you would like.
And then, just I have to
enter in my AD credentials.
This is service
account credentials,
so I'll just do it quickly.
Got that right.
And then, I'm going
to get hit Create.
So while it's going
off in the background,
I'm just going to go and show
you the view of the Remote
Workstations page.
So these are the three
remote workstations
I've previously set
up as well as the one
that's being created right now.
So you can see they're running.
With most virtual workstations
you might be familiar with,
you can start, stop, restart,
and delete them, as well as
edit.
I'm just going to edit one,
just to quickly show you.
Here is all my users in my AD.
So I can assign Ryan Meadows and
Adam, add him to this list such
that when he logs in
with his AD credentials
he'll be presented with
this remote workstation
so this person can go access it.
One thing I want to
mention, this whole frontend
that you're seeing is
using our backend APIs,
and we plan to make those
backend APIs publicly
available for our partners.
This can be really
useful if you're
wanting to build your own
solution on top of ours.
So you can add
your own value add.
You might be wanting to
automate a lot of this stuff.
Well, I expect you will.
So using those APIs,
as you can automate it
and actually not have
to go through this UI.
But the UI is a really good way
to show how things are setup
as well as for
monitoring things.
And I'm just going to quickly
show the power management
side of things.
So here's a machine that
is in the stop state.
And what I'm going to do, I'm
going to start up a third PCoIP
session.
I'll enter in the same
IP address as before.
OK.
And the machine, I
believe, was stage-vfx-1.
That's in the stop state.
Yes, it is.
OK.
So I'm just going
to go connect to it,
establish a PCoIP connection.
So back in the client, it
said it was actually starting.
Now, if I go back to
the Remote Workstations,
it says it's starting here.
One of the neat things
about the GCP machines
is they start up really fast.
So within less than a minute,
this machine will be running.
And then, your user will
automatically connect to it.
It's important to keep
control of your costs
because running machines in the
cloud, especially the GPU ones,
can run up a large bill.
So some users like
to turn them off when
they're not being used.
OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]